all right we got a lot to go over today
let's start with uh hash rate obviously
last year we saw china go ahead and kick
out you know 60 plus percent of the hash
rate hatch rate went down more than 50
percent uh it's come roaring back you've
got this chart here uh around the
seven day average and also the 30-day
growth what what is this showing you and
why do you think it's so important
yeah so i started the slide deck off
today with just a couple
of the kind of the fundamentals so
obviously uh network security hash rate
matters uh
a lot for for the bitcoin network uh but
it's something that you might not see
when you're just looking at the ticker
symbol and then the price move up and
down so uh hash rate we like to look at
you know the seven day average some
people do you know 14 day two week
average a month average uh but basically
because of like the day-to-day variance
of of these block times coming in um you
know the moving averages provides a
little more signal so seven day moving
average network's above 200 x a hash
it's honestly quite historic um just
given like the breadth of the drawdown
in 2021 uh you kind of in that in the
second pane in the bottom of the chart
we see that 30-day uh growth and besides
basically that uh the china event you
see just how the hash rate relentlessly
growing um so the fundamentals of
bitcoin have never been stronger network
security up and to the right uh and it's
becoming a lot more competitive to mine
bitcoin uh actually with hash rate
rising and the price kind of
consolidating it puts a little bit of
compression on some of these minor
margins which is what we've talked about
a lot some of the publicly traded miners
uh denominating them in btc terms it
gets quite interesting if hatch rate
continues to kind of hockey stick
upwards um and i think that's that'll be
the story of the next decade is just
hashrate relentlessly uh bending upwards
a lot of analysts think that 300 extra
hash is in the future for 2022. uh we'll
have to see but a lot of publicly traded
miners are you know are pretty
optimistic about that so uh definitely
an encouraging sign in general though of
network security yeah it's absolutely
incredible to watch just how quickly it
uh kind of uh came back how resilient
the network's been uh and continue to
hit those all-time highs another area of
massive growth recently has been the
lightning network and every single time
i go and i look at these statistics i'm
personally just shocked and i'm you know
as bullish as they come but the growth
seems to be even outpacing my
expectations what are you seeing here
with the lightning network public
channel capacity
yeah so i mean the lightning network is
not something that gets talked about a
lot in crypto spheres it's kind of just
this thing that's that's being worked on
under the hood uh and a lot of these
like you know open source protocols uh
apps different like something like
strike right where it's almost
abstracted away where you don't even
know you're using lightning you're just
scanning a qr code i think that's the
future and what it allows for is this
monetary asset to be settled basically
instantaneously uh anywhere in the world
so jack muller's is having a talk with
the imf saying this isn't even about
bitcoin the asset this is about bitcoin
the network
uh and lightning the network which is a
layer layer two on top of a bitcoin just
being a superior monetary network
compared to anything the world's ever
seen and the reality is that almost no
one in the world understands that fact
yet
that we can settle without without
really any counterparty risk we can
settle this absolutely scarce monetary
asset uh in a bearer type way from
peer-to-peer uh with no intermediary
with uh no counterparty and with no
really risk of um you know funds being
seized or anything else that you that
you deal with on a traditional kind of
third party uh settlement network or
third party like like a visa paypal et
cetera satoshi solved that double spend
problem and lightning allowed for uh
allows for this instantaneous type
settlement so it's really exciting and a
lot of really smart people and engineers
and founders are building on top of this
thing so you know we're going to see you
know more countries adopt this as legal
tender in the future i think that's
that's not even a real bold prediction
and you know the medium of exchange type
uh side of bitcoin is really going to
utilize lightning network yeah it's
pretty crazy to think about uh the
lightning network uh without all the
hype right for the most part uh without
tons of venture backing um and uh it's
just been volunteers on the internet
kind of slowly but surely building uh a
peer-to-peer network of um you know what
at now is probably tens of thousands of
people uh running these uh lightning
network nodes uh all throughout the uh
through the world and uh really building
a actual decentralized system uh that
has uh instantaneous settlement uh
nearly free from a fee perspective uh
and at the end of the day is superior to
the legacy banking system right if i
want to send any amount of money uh even
if it is uh using my credit card at the
coffee shop etc there is not cash
finality there is not uh instantaneous
settlement there is not nearly free uh
you know from a fee perspective and so
this is superior technology and people
around the world are adopting it and i
think you see it in some of these
metrics that you're pointing out here
let's talk about uh exchange flows i
know you've been looking a lot at that
you've got the 30 day
kind of analysis of uh exchange flows
what is this telling us
yeah so um you know people try to get a
little too fancy with exchange flows and
use it as a top or a bottom indicator
and a lot of times it's not that simple
but
i think we can identify a few secular
trends here um one is that exchange
flows are basically persistently
negative for the most part so coins are
coming off exchanges except for a few
just type of uh you know big events we
saw
with the china exodus and kind of that
liquidation event that happened that
mass liquidation event in the may of
2021 saw a lot of coins flowing
exchanges we saw uh following the powell
kind of pivot uh and inflation's not
transitory in november we saw some coins
come on to exchange but really the trend
since the start of 2020 has been coins
are flowing out of exchanges by the
hundreds of thousands uh and just huge
numbers and so i think that trend is set
to continue and there will be you know
bumps in the road you know there will be
coins coming on exchanges at certain
times maybe the next time all-time high
breaks but the reality is uh people are
increasingly coming to realize that
bitcoin and the native kind of
properties of this asset that allow you
to self-custody it are really important
uh you know talking about trudeau
and canada earlier i i caught a little
bit of you guys before i came on uh you
know this this whole thing with covet a
lot of people are realizing it's not
about health uh and increasingly it's
just about control
and so you know money that can't be
seized money that's not a database entry
in someone else's database where you
know if your political you know views
don't align with theirs well your money
might not be yours um so bitcoin in that
sense is more important than ever and
increasingly people are coming to
realize that so you know self-custody
your coins not your keys not your coins
it's the story of bitcoin yeah and it's
only gonna get louder and more prominent
i think uh we've got the illiquid supply
shock ratio here what is this telling us
yeah so shout out will clemente uh came
up with this one uh in in 2021 uh and on
chain what you can really see is it
quantifies the supply side of things uh
and and really this this primes uh or
sets the stage for for the demand side
so so price runs when the marginal
seller is exhausted and what we see here
is that just
the marginal seller really just kind of
this cohort of stackers uh is is taking
over and so just continuing to eat away
at that free flow of supply uh
diminishing that available you know
bitcoin to be sold on the market uh
every single day and so a liquid supply
this the supply shock ratio quantifying
uh the liquid supply relative to the
liquid and highly liquid supply uh you
know don't have to get too much into the
wheats with the definitions but
basically it's just showing uh you know
how much bitcoin is being is is being
held by its strong hands uh relative to
that kind of that liquid supply and so
it's it's as attractive as it's as it's
been since the start of 2020 surpassing
its 2021 highs
and so really what we're waiting for is
this big demand shift and i think we're
starting to see it not even from the
inflation hedge narrative this digital
gold narrative the central bank dilution
narrative that we saw in 2020 21 but now
we're seeing more so the censorship
resistance uh kind of effect play uh or
start to play out and so
really interesting time in bitcoin uh
but the demand side really what are the
supply side what this is showing is that
uh we're primed for for a big move when
that kind of demand shifts and comes in
a big way
yeah it's pretty incredible to watch
this um speaking of kind of this
illiquid uh supply shock one of the big
things that uh you know we've heard
everyone from stanley druckenmiller paul
tudor jones talk about is this idea that
bitcoiners don't sell right for the most
part and the majority of them continue
to hold for long periods of time for
those that don't know the story i
believe it was paul tudor jones called
stanley druckenmiller uh back in 2018 uh
kind of beginning of 2019 he said hey do
you want to hear a crazy stat it's like
87 percent or some you know crazy high
number of bitcoiners who held bitcoin
when it was at twenty thousand haven't
sold even though it dropped all the way
down to around three thousand dollars
and of course they then said well that's
pretty interesting and and uh ended up
going ahead and getting themselves and
many others to
actually start to allocate to the asset
class uh you've got this uh chart here
that shows that 60 of circulating supply
has been dormant for one plus year
how do you evaluate whether that's a
good number a bad number is it going
higher is it going lower like how do you
evaluate this
yeah so i mean there's not too much like
directional analysis that that you can
apply here i think really it's just the
story of like it's more so just kind of
quantifying what the people like stan
druckenmiller and palter jones when they
decide to allocate a big chunk to this
asset class what they're seeing and it's
that you know there's this cohort of
people around the world of investors um
maybe not even investors maybe just
savers
that come to realize the properties of
bitcoin and say i want to hold as much
of this as i can and so you're seeing
like recently that the supply dormant
for one year is hockey sticking up and
to the right um and so you can kind of
think of that as being bullish in itself
you know that free flow of supply
available is becoming less and less
but really it's just showing that you
know up down sideways there's people
that understand that bitcoin's the best
money ever and they're they're
you know getting their fair share and so
you know proof of work you gotta you
gotta put in uh some sort of capital or
you gotta you know energy expenditure to
acquire your fair share of this 21
million so uh yeah i think that's just
the story and this you know one year
dormant supply is a pretty interesting
metric to look at over time yeah and
when you look at that number how much of
that is driven by uh potentially lost
coins or other you know types of assets
that uh or other holders that might not
just be you know strong holders that are
never gonna sell but could be destroyed
lost or anything like that
yeah i think i've seen some pretty good
estimates about you know two to three
million coins lost i mean i would
certainly say satoshi's million-ish
stack is is gone forever uh whether
purposefully or not um and so probably
the the real like you know total
available supply is somewhere around 18
million uh i think i mean 19 million
coins are in circulation right now
um and so you know total total supply
available i guess you could think of
like 15 million or so but really uh if
you're looking at a lot of these like
you know autometrics liquid supply type
stuff i would say only probably about a
few million coins are i guess up for
sale if you want to call them and really
like
you know price set at the margin it's
it's only a few hundred thousand coins
that are deciding this this daily price
the rest is just being huddled by people
that have no interest in exchanging back
for fiat currency because they
understand the end game
yeah you've got this uh statistic here
that says 1.4 trillion dollars an
immutable value transfer so far in 2022
that is a massive number uh and would
put us on pace to destroy uh mastercard
and number of other payment systems from
just a a value transfer standpoint uh
what what's your analysis on this
yeah so i mean i really could have just
said uh you know 1.426 trillion and
change adjusted volume but you know if
we're if we're just thinking about
recent events thinking about what's
happening in canada uh really you know
freedom money rings and so uh immutable
value transfer like the value prop there
a lot of people in western countries for
the longest time said you know what's
the point when i can just transfer money
on
you know ach or stripe or you know venmo
what's the point of bitcoin it's it's
slow and efficient and all these other
things and then the reality is they say
a wrong thing or attend the wrong
protest and nope all of a sudden your
bank your money that you thought you had
isn't your money um and so like you know
it's kind of somewhat dystopian but the
reality is that bitcoin and it and it's
uh you know value prop has has never
been clearer for a lot of people and so
the reality is that you know this this
monetary network and its properties
aren't aren't you know duplicable
anywhere else in the world this proof of
work the kind of settlement assurances
that come with this this protocol um
don't exist in other crypto currencies
and they don't exist in the legacy
system and so you know this increasing
trend towards overreach uh by
governments and really you know tyrants
is not something that that we want to
see but it's just the reality of how the
world works and how it's you know where
it's where we're going and so uh you
know central bank digital currencies a
lot of this stuff uh it's really
somewhat of a you know less less freedom
for for all of us and so to have bitcoin
here to have this freedom money is
something that you know can't be
understated and that's why we keep
emphasizing it over and over got it and
then when you start to actually look at
uh at this last chart the cpi
year-over-year versus the fed funds uh
effective rate obviously uh we've got
tons of talk of inflation of fed policy
decisions uh-huh seven and a half
percent uh is a freaking wild number
what what's uh what's the read
all right so i'm gonna read an excerpt
from an imf paper in 2011 uh and so just
so people like kind of you know get some
context to what what we're dealing with
here so uh this was published in 2011 by
the imf says a subtle type of debt
restructuring takes a form of financial
repression financial repression includes
direct lending to governments by captive
domestic audiences such as pension funds
explicit or implicit cap on interest
rates regulation of cross-border capital
movements and a generally tighter
connection between government and banks
in a heavily regulated financial markets
of the bretton woods system several
restrictions facilitated a sharp and
rapid reduction in public debt to gdp
ratios from 1940s to 1970s low nominal
rates
no low nominal interest rates help
reduce debt servicing costs while high
incidence of negative real interest
rates liquidate or erode the value of
government debt so what's happening high
inflation low interest rates domestic
captive pension funds and all these you
know other sort of sorts of capital are
you know sitting in bonds tens of
trillions of dollars worth what's
happening
the real value of that capital is
eroding in real time so so what we can
take from this well uh it's not so much
you know a coincidence more so that
they're following a playbook
and if you're sitting in bonds if you're
sitting in debt securities you're
guaranteed to lose
um so thankfully we have an escape valve
uh christine lagarde the chair of the
ecb said you know if there's an escape
valve they'll use it and the reality is
that bitcoin uh increasingly is becoming
this escape valve for people and not
many people realize it and a lot of
people deny this fact that it's some
sort of inflation hedge but i wouldn't
think of it as a you know inflation
hedge on the cpi reading on a wednesday
or thursday morning uh that's kind of
missing the force for the trees uh the
rea the reality is that digital gold
this absolutely scarce monetary asset
that can't be censored that can't be
taken away from you is this hedge
against government tyranny but also
financial repression uh which is the
only way out of this this you know
unprecedented debt spiral that
everywhere in the world seems to find
themselves in so uh you know it's it's
more of a playbook than anything else
and i think uh you know you'd be wise to
have some bitcoin in your portfolio
what's your read on the canadian uh
government bitcoin freezing assets the
whole nine yards
yeah i mean a lot of things to say and i
think uh you know i've i've definitely
made my opinion kind of uh loud and
clear on twitter and i've had a lot of
people you know uh give me their you
know or i guess like frown upon my take
that it's not about health and i think
it's becoming increasingly obvious that
it's not about health and it never
really was and so you're seeing you know
places like canada and australia and new
zealand uh you know clamp down super
hard on their citizens
um and it's it's scary it's definitely
scary i mean i live you know an hour
from the canadian border and probably
won't go for a long time so uh you know
bitcoin is hope for these people and you
know uh freedom money rings uh i guess
that's all i have to say in regards to
that but i think uh trudeau and uh a lot
of those you know government cronies are
on the wrong side of history
joe john what questions you guys got
dylan what's up man i like the mustache
keep that going don't let him uh him
come after you all right um my question
would just be around the supply side uh
and the buyers right so i think we've
seen we've talked about this multiple
times of how retail continues to buy and
just dollar cost average into this asset
uh time over time again but from the
institutional side like what are you
looking for there and and like i guess
from like a bull case scenario if we
think if bitcoin's gonna go where we all
think it's eventually gonna go like how
much of that is institutional based
versus just the retailers continuing to
to buy into this asset
yeah so i mean retail was definitely um
you know they were like here to bitcoin
almost a decade before a lot of this
like institutional capital uh and you
know that ever-growing base of retail
buyers is is still going strong but i
think the institutional capital that's
you know moving that's moving funds off
of like say the real yields
and looking like or say like pensions
endowments all these uh other sort of
funds they're trading off what's
happening in legacy markets uh and
somewhat of a risk off sentiment uh and
price action and equity markets and
credit markets uh like we've covered in
previous episodes that definitely has an
effect on on their allocation and where
they're moving capital um so that's kind
of why we're seeing i think some sort of
consolidation for the time being um
you're seeing certainly some
institutions or maybe uh the ones that
are a little more prudent uh are saying
hey we need that we need to up our
bitcoin allocation uh in times of
uncertainty because not only is there
inflation risk but there's credit risk
everywhere in the fiat system uh but you
know for the most part i think we've
seen somewhat of a halted kind of
uh
allocation from a lot of these these big
money funds until
uh more like central banks kind of uh go
off their hawkish stance with a little
bit so even though inflate even though
inflation's seven percent and the you
know fed funds is still
zero and the ten-year treasury's still
at two percent uh yields are laughably
still you know very negative uh in real
terms but i think they'll be a pivot uh
they can't taper a ponzi essentially and
so that's when you know a lot of this
institutional capital comes back in a
big big way
gotcha
russia excuse me
russia has obviously been in the news a
lot lately but recently they came out
and we're talking about lower taxes for
people using electricity for crypto
mining what is your sediment about all
that and kind of they now i believe in
august of last year had around 11
of the bitcoin mining in the world what
is your read around what's going on over
there not trying to get political
yeah by no means a you know a
geopolitical analyst i would just i
would just say that russia uh you know
very uh natural resource rich uh you
know they export a lot of energy
obviously um and you know they've
increasingly tried to
basically get off the dollar system uh
get off that kind of swift fedwire
system uh de-dollarize their reserves
they're holding uh you know a lot less
treasuries and a lot more gold and so i
think bitcoin's a natural fit uh whether
you know putin straight up adopts it as
as you know legal tender or currency or
they buy bitcoin for for reserves that's
another story but i think it just it
naturally makes sense i think it would
be you know a blunder of a move if they
did something similar to what china did
in terms of you know just kicking all
their miners out it makes it makes
almost no sense and so i think it
actually the game theory says they they
embrace it and whether they explicitly
embrace it and come out as as you know
proponents and supporters is another
story uh but you know it's a quite
natural fit given that you know the
natural resources in russia and also
just like the geopolitical environment
and you know the history of u.s
sanctions and and all the likes so i
think it's a natural fit and we'll see
where it goes but the game theory says
you know full go for for putin and
russia with bitcoin well said dylan last
question we have for you uh you don't
know this because it happened while
we've been talking but uh conoco
phillips was a 100 billion dollar
oil producer
they've publicly just announced and
admitted that they are actually mining
bitcoin uh in the uh i think is
pronounced bacon or a bakken uh kind of
formation which is in kind of central
part of the united states so we've got
one of the largest oil producers uh in
the world that now is saying yes we are
mining bitcoin uh within the borders of
the united states what's your general
take on
on these energy companies doing this and
and kind of not talking about it looks
like
gradually then suddenly uh yeah i mean
it's all coming they're all gonna come
uh i mean right now the production cost
of bitcoin i mean it varies based on you
know your cost of power and your uh your
rate cost but you know a lot of these
publicly traded miners are producing
bitcoin for ten thousand dollars with
the market price of forty four thousand
so uh and a lot of like uh you know say
like great american mining and a couple
of these uh companies are just taking
like waste natural gas in the in the
bakken where these guys i guess just
said they're mining bitcoin and they
have almost no marginal uh
marginal cost to this it's waste energy
and they're mining bitcoin with it and
so uh you know every oil and gas company
is gonna is gonna enter the space in a
big big way uh and so i think you know
we're still at the phase where it's a
lot of the kind of early adopters
but you know the just the financial
incentives alone say they're all going
to come so you know gradually then
suddenly and it's nice to see another
one another one of those dominoes fall
i completely agree with that um last uh
last last question uh sentiment check
from you uh obviously with bitcoin kind
of going a little sideways here uh
people seem to be a little bit quieter
on the internet what's your general take
as to where we are and kind of what to
expect over the next couple of weeks
uh yeah i mean i think equities uh
equities are still a big driver uh risk
on risk off uh you know what what's
happening whether you know there's a
deleveraging in the in the legacy system
or not i've been watching credit markets
quite closely uh they still don't look
too great we covered that on the last
show
so i think that's kind of interim you
know short-term risks um but i mean i
came out and i said uh i think it was
about two weeks ago uh glad i increased
my bitcoin allocation to 105 so i mean
i'm long and strong
no no wavering beliefs here uh nothing's
changed in that in that sense
i love it joe john you guys got anything
else no man dylan thanks for coming on
man
thanks to you guys dylan you continue to
kill it my friend where are we at with
the uh little twitter check
122. how's the newsletter going dylan
it's going great yeah we're pumping out
daily content uh released our monthly
report last week got a lot of good
feedback there it was a in a pdf format
and looked pretty clean so yeah it's
going great like to put out uh you know
good research you know almost daily uh
it's hard to to pump it out daily but we
try to make it work nice
let's do it my friend all right we
appreciate you keep up the great work
see you next tuesday
peace later buddy